Welcome everybody.
This is the second webinar for cloud products.
Today we will talk about using BigQuery to
explore and search the SRA metadata available.
Before we get started with the actual presentation,
I would like you to take a poll for us about
your familiarity with SQL and BigQuery.
You can click on the screen to answer the
question.
And when we get some responses, I will close
it and share it with everybody.
This kind of helps me to tailor the webinar
to your needs.
So that I can go into more detail about certain
things or less detail.
It looks like most of you have heard of SQL
but have not actually used it.
We have another poll for if you have used
BigQuery.
So besides helping tailor this to the webinar,
it helps us understand your use cases and
the products we are building to meet your
needs.
It looks like most of you have heard of or
used BigQuery.
For some of you, this is the first experience
you will have with it.
I'm glad to be able to explain it.
So a quick introduction for the agenda.
I will go through SRA in the Cloud and what
BigQuery is and after that short introduction,
I will jump straight into the actual demo
of the three use cases we will be doing today.
As far as the cloud, what is it?
We have moved all of our data to the clouds
and more than 12 gigabytes to the cloud.
This number grows daily.
Having all the data doesn't help anybody because
you need a way of actually searching for the
right data sets.
This is where BigQuery comes and this is our
first cloud native product for doing search
for data sets is.
And it has two major benefits.
One is it has a fast response to the queries
you will run and the multiple methods you
can use to access it.
It has a web interface, it has a command line
API.
It has multiple libraries you can use in the
programming languages like Python.
And also getting started with SQL is fairly
easy.
There are only a handful of concepts you need
to understand before you can dive in and start
exploring it.
If you are interested to learn more about
SQL, Google has made a lot of efforts to provide
documentation for BigQuery.
They have query syntax explanations.
They have tutorials.
They have how to documents.
Besides what Google provides, there are a
lot of tutorials and web classes you can sign
up for.
Some of them are free and some of them are
paid where you can learn SQL as well.
Also search forums for questions on how to
write queries.
One of the popular ones is [indiscernable].
You can submit a question and people will
help you answer it.
There are also a lot of questions being asked
already so you can certainly reuse those answers
provided.
And so BigQuery is just a giant data warehouse.
They have deposited two datasets into it.
The first is the SRA metadata that includes
sample information and how the sample is sequenced
and basic statistics on the sequencing run.
A second dataset we have is the SRA taxonomic
content analysis done using a kmer approach
and we predict species based on these unique
kmers.
And you can take results from both of the
data sets and combine them in a query.
This will help you have a more filtered result
depending on the case.
So a quick overview about SQL.
There is a SELECT statement that tells we
will be extracting data from tables.
There is the FROM clause that will tell the
database, from what tables we will be extracting
data from.
There is the WHERE clause that specifies the
filters we are applying to the tables.
And a common one to use as use as ORDER BY,
which helps to order the dataset based on
a particular column.
It could be release date or accession numbers.
There are other operators using SQL.
Some of these are the =-equals-sign.
Others you will see in my queries are the
In operator used to provide a list to a particular
column.
There is the UNnest which flattens an array
into its own table and the Like operator which
allows you to do patterns searches.
You will see those in my cases.
We have three cases we will demo.
One is finding the taxonomic distribution
of human gut meta- genomes.
The second is finding coronaviridae data in
SRA and the third is identifying runs for
Arabidopsis gene expression studies.
At this point, I will jump straight into the
actual demo.
Here we have my first query which is finding
taxonomic content in human gut metagenomes.
This takes about 30 seconds to run.
To go over the syntax here.
I'm selecting only three columns.
I'm selecting the accession column, the name
column and a column called self_count which
represents the number of kmer hits.
In the FROM clause I have two tables.
One is the SRA metadata,
'nih-sra-datastore.sra.metadata',
where I'm providing the alias m.
And I have the SRA tax analysis tool table,
'nih-sra-datastore.sra_tax_analysis_tool.tax_analysis'
and the alias for that is tax.
So the alias is just to make it easier to
write queries.
And you don't have to rewrite the entire tablename
every time.
I am then joining the two tables based on
accession columns.
I am providing a list of organisms to search
in the metadata table for the organism column.
And I'm looking for only public data sets.
These data sets are publicly available and
don't require any permission to access.
BigQuery does have dbGaP data in it.
And so in order to make sure I don't need
to apply for special access to the studies,
I'm just looking for public data.
And filtering the results and providing only
the results for the species.
The taxonomic analysis table contains the
entire taxonomic tree for each species identified.
And if you are interested in seeing the whole
tree, you can certainly pull that out.
For this example, I just want the actual species
living in the human gut metagenome.
So a couple things you can pay attention to
on the web interface is, they identify how
much data will be processed with a query here
on the right-hand side.
And it provides a quick check that there are
no syntax errors in the query.
So this is kind of a quick check you can do
to make sure the query is fine.
Now that we have our results, we have our
accessions column, the name for the species
within this accession, and the number of kmer
hits.
Looking at this, we can see the result came
back with roughly 39 million rows.
This is a lot of data here.
You can quickly scan through by eye if you
want.
But we don't want to scan through 40 million
rows.
So the next step might be, how do you visualize
something like this?
What do you do to visualize in an easy manner?
There are a couple of ways ways you can do
this.
The first step would be to save the results
somewhere.
Unfortunately, Google does provide certain
limits to what you can save to a file directly
from running a query.
In this case, there is the one gigabyte limit
or if you are saving to a local file, you
can save 16,000 rows.
However, there is an option to save the results
as its own BigQuery table and this is what
you will actually need to do.
Once you have saved it as the BigQuery table,
you have a couple of different options.
You can send the the entire table to Google's
Data Studio.
And use that to visualize the data and do
graphs and dashboards for data.
Or if you want to run your own statistical
analysis on the data you can save the entire
table as a file.
This is why you need to save the results as
a table so you can send an export command
either through the web interface command line
or through one of those libraries I mentioned
for programming languages for exporting the
entire table into a file, into a Google bucket.
When the export is finished, you have a file
which you can work on.
However, if you do want to get that file to
your local computer, you would need to pay
egress charges to download the data from your
Google bucket into your local computer.
Depending on the use case and where you want
to perform the analysis, those are some of
the different options available for you to
for you to work with such a large dataset
as this.
However, this can provide you some input about
what species live in human gut metagenomes
so I think this is very useful.
So now we will move forward to the second
use case.
And you can see that I saved all of my use
cases as queries which is easy to do.
You can click save query and save as and provide
any name you want to it.
So for our second use case, finding coronaviridae
dataset, let me just open the query anrd run
it very quickly.
This is a much much smaller dataset that we
are querying, so comes back significantly
faster.
In this case, what I'm looking for is the
bioproject, the biosample accessions, the
run accessions, the collection date, the geo
location of where the sample was collected,
who it was collected by, and the host of the
sample.
Just like last time, I'm querying the metadata
table and the taxonomy analysis table.
What I'm searching for in this case is the
Coronaviridae family.
Instead of looking for a particular species
or all species, I'm applying to a particular
family that I'm looking for.
As you can see, we have a lot of good metadata
like inn these first examples where we have
a collection date, the location and who was
collected by, and the host.
As you can see, there are data sets that don't
have a lot have a lot of metadata.
It is one of those challenges with working
with user submitted data.
What you might expect to be there might not
be there because it was never submitted to
NCBI.
Or in this case to EBI, since this is an ENA
accession.
However, you can use these datasets to identify
runs that will be useful for the analysis.
In case you are interested in the human based
hosts you can pull out the accessions, save
those to a file, and feed those to the SRA
toolkit to dump fastq files or sam files and
then run your computational tools on those
files.
To make things easier within BigQuery, which
provides a lot of useful tools and shortcuts.
One of these is an autocomplete feature.
If I started writing something, and in this
case, I want to filter the dataset based on
when the data sets were released.
I'm going to search the metadata table, and
I just hit tab.
And I could see all the columns within the
metadata table.
And if I start just typing what I want, which
is the release date, it will select the date
for me.
In this case, I can find the column that I
want using this autocomplete feature.
If you want to learn more about shortcuts,
there is this shortcut tool that you can look
through and see different shortcuts available
for you.
In this case, if I wanted to filter by release
date, I could say I want all the samples that
were released within this year.
And so it makes it very easy to write your
queries using this feature.
You don't have to memorize all the columns
available in all of the tables.
So the last example here is finding the arabidopsis
dataset for RNA-seq analysis.
In this case, this query is a little more
complicated.
Because I'm working with a lot more data submitted
by users.
In this case, what I'm what I'm doing is,
I'm opening the attributes column within the
metadata table.
And this column is an array so I use the unnest
operator to make it a flat table.
And I'm looking for all the keys with the
name, tissue, organism_part or organ_sample.
And I'm providing an alias called tissue,
so I can quickly identify where the tissue
was for the dataset.
Next, I'm looking for what the treatment was
for the dataset.
I basically copied and pasted the above query
and changed the keys to treatment, environment_stress
and condition for this sample.
So how do I know what keys to use in this
column?
That was a more complicated step where I looked
through different examples of different samples.
And I printed these out and saved them as
a list to be used in this query.
There will be work trying to identify the
correct keys to use because different submitters
like to provide different attribute names
when they are submitting metadata.
It makes it hard to standardize searches like
this.
And so besides that I'm also going to pull
out all the metadata columns, but I'm providing
the EXCEPT operator here.
Because I don't want these five columns to
be displaced.
Instead of typing out the metadata accessions,
assay type, and all the other columns I want
to display.
It is quicker to supply a list of columns
I don't want to display.
For the FROM clause, I am providing the metadata
table with the alias.
And I'm going to UNnest again the attributes
array as its own table.
BigQuery will join these these two tables
on the back end so you don't have to worry
about them.
The filters we are applying here is the actual
organism name and I will search through the
simple attributes looking for the key words
either leaf, root or leaves.
And then the other approach I took is the
metadata has this column called JATTR.
And this is the json attributes column where
we took all the virus sample attributes and
provided them as json.
Here I am searching based on a pattern for
the word drought.
The % sign will apply one or more characters
before or after the word drought.
I'm doing abroad search here.
And to make sure I'm pulling out the gene
expression ones, I provided the librarysource
transcriptomic.
And the assay_type is set to RNA-Seq.
And this could potentially be another filter
you apply.
Looking at the results we have roughly 300
datasets where the tissue is either leaf or
root and where the treatment relates to drought.
Having looked at this and maybe picking out
some other attributes to filter the dataset,
maybe by sequencing platform or what selection
strategy was used, I can narrow the dataset
even further.
Now that you have this, the idea is you pull
out the run accessioins and get the actual
data to run some bioinformatics RNA-Seq computation
on it.
So those are the three use cases I wanted
to provide to you.
Go through the queries and use them and potentially
use the results.
Now, running BigQuery is not free but it is
very cheap.
So here is a quick predicted cost for running
these queries.
As you can see our biggest one was the human
gut meta- genome where we extracted 40 million
rows and that only costs roughly 40 cents.
The Coronaviridae dataset was significantly
smaller and was only 30 cents.
And the ARABIDOPSIS was only 10 cents.
Getting started with BigQuery is very cheap.
We are always looking for feedback.
The only way we know how to improve our tools
and to know what we are doing is if the community
speaks to us.
If you have suggestions for improvement, do
not hesitate to contact us.
Just write to, suggest@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov and
provide us with any feedback on things that
we are doing well or things he could improve
to fit your use cases.
The more we hear from you, the better we can
provide the tools you need for research.
Here are some general URLs that you can look
for, for more information.
We have more documentation available about
BigQuery and access to data in the cloud at
SRA.
If you want to learn more about exporting
large datasets, Google does provide directions
for that.
If you want to play around with Data Studio
there is documentation available for that.
And please sigh up for our YouTube channel
as we will hold more webinars and provide
more instructional videos.
All videos will be available there.
So it is a good resource to have for you.
And that is about it.
Thank you.
[Peter Cooper] Thanks Yuriy.
We have a few questions and the questions
pod.
There have been some questions about cost.
You did a good job of explaining costs for
those particular queries.
There is a free tier is there not?
Can you run these on the free tier?
[Yuriy Skripchenko] There Google does provide
kind of a free tier approach where the number
of queries is limited but you could do that.
And if you sign up for BigQuery yourself,
Google provides you one terabyte of data to
process free every single month.
It is possible to sign up and set a limit
for yourself for how much data you want to
process.
And just stay within that one terabyte free
limit which I think will be higher than the
free tier.
But that part I'm not quite sure about.
There certainly is free tier for BigQuery.
[Peter Cooper] Another question.
Actually there are a couple related questions.
And it has to do with the columns and the
keys that you search on.
I think this was the Arabidopsis example.
One question is, what happens if there are
multiple key matches?
What results do you get back?
For example, the information about treatment
could be three possible keys I think.
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Right.
It is certainly possible.
In this case, there wasn't any overlap in
these three keys.
[Peter Cooper] But it is possible there could
be?
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Yes.
Potentially, that that could be.
I would actually need to explore that and
how this query would act that way.
[Peter Cooper] I think it was a general question
as to how it would behave.
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Yes.
This is the complication with having user
submitted metadata where the keys can change
and different submitters will use different
keys to mean the same thing.
So you need to be very careful about how you
use those keys and you might potentially run
into an error on the result depending how
the query is structured.
So it does take some playing around with the
query to get the exact result that you want.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you.
Related to that is this concept of the user
submitted data having lack of control I guess
is one way of putting it.
Someone wanted to know if NCBI had done any
work to group related columns so that it would
be easier for people to make a precise queries.
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Right.
So NCBI does try to standardize the metadata
that we request from people during submission
time, that helps.
We have not had the chance to do more work
on standardizing the metadata but it is certainly
something that we are aware of that needs
to happen and we will be working on it in
in the future to make this process easier
when writing queries.
At this time, we have not dug too deep into
it simply because of the complexity of the
task but it is something on the roadmap.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you.
Another question is about, is there a way
to run a query.
Suppose you ran a query today and you want
want to run a query a month later but you
want to only query the new data.
The stuff that has come and in the past month
to save money basically.
Is there a way to there a way to do that?
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Not yet as far as I understand
how BigQuery works.
It searches the entire dataset for results.
You can certainly set filters for when the
data might have been submitted or released.
So the return would be smaller.
But BigQuery will still search the entire
dataset.
[Peter Cooper] I see, so that would be applied
after the search.
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Yes.
[Peter Cooper] Okay.
Another question which has to do with diagramming
the database.
Is there a UML or ER model of the SRA tables?
[Yuriy Skripchenko] We provide schemas in
the documentation that are available at SRA.
So if we go to the SRA landing page.
We have SRA in the cloud here.
Within Search using BigQuery we have links
to the actual tables and some explanations
of what columns can be used.
We did not put together a full UML diagram.
But you also can link the entire project,
if you go to Pin a project you would need
to type in nih-sra-datastore.
Then click PIN.
And you would be able to take take a look
at what is available within BigQuery.
You can take a look at the tables and see
what columns and types are available and what
is available within BigQuery.
Here you can take a look at the tables.
And see what columns and types are available
for all of these data tables from within BigQuery.
It is a good idea to build the UML diagrams.
[Peter Cooper] Okay thanks.
And there is another question that you may
have addressed in the last webinar.
Someone is asking if we have a pipeline available
that they can submit data.
It looks like they are trying to filter out
contamination from the data.
[Yuriy Skripchenko] I don't quite understand
the question here.
A Pipeline to submit data?
The metadata?
[Peter Cooper] I'm not sure.
I think they were asking about contamination
of the data that they want to filter out.
I'm not sure what kind of contamination.
Maybe human sequences in metagenome data or
something like that.
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Okay.
We do have a process for filtering out human
data from datasets.
Whether the dataset is submitted to NCBI,
if the submitter contacts SRA and tells us
they want to perform human filtering on the
dataset we can activate the process.
We have not built that into our submission
interface yet to allow the submitter to do
that themselves.
We can certainly do that and we have a process
for that.
We are working on a publication for that process
at this moment and once the publication is
made, we will be linking it to the webpages.
[Peter Cooper] Great.
Very helpful.
I think we have addressed all the questions.
Thank you everybody for coming.
Thank you, Yuriy.
[Yuriy Skripchenko] Thank you everybody for
joining us.
[Peter Cooper] I will go ahead and end the
webinar.